[Music]
mr. O'Reilly 300ccs don't name our
canoes no visible earth it has the scale
of America's National Mall and the
seriousness of Pearl Harbor combine them
and that's what it feels like to visit
mammoth Gorgon the memorial complex for
the Battle of Stalingrad over 1 million
Russian soldiers fell here it is a place
of healing for veterans the city and the
entire country the heart of the complex
is the immense Statute motherland calls
nearly twice as tall as the Statue of
Liberty its power lies not only what is
seen but also in what lies beneath below
its base lay the remains of nearly
35,000 unidentified soldiers it's
staggering size represents not only the
huge price paid by the Russian people in
the war but also its enormous meaning in
every Russians heart it notes in a much
that the speeches know
what this reevaluate mamaev Corgan isn't
just a place of mourning it's also one
of hope entering the Hall of warrior
glory feels like stepping into memorial
service the hands stretching from the
ground carries the flame of peace on the
fallen to the future generations both of
my grandfather's fought in World War two
although I found my visit to my myath
gorgon emotionally difficult it is one I
will never forget
[Music]